I love that you went all black how did
you hear about it when did you decide to
join it did you get a call from someone
I think it's impossible not to hear
about it's an incredibly important issue
and I think everyone rattling lending
their voice in whatever way they can is
a beautiful thing and I'm trying to do
my part how can we change what is the
change that needs to be happen and you
know what is what is there a mark that
we're gonna hit and we'll be like oh
everything's changed times I don't think
in issues ever fully solved you know I
think the key is just starting a
conversation bringing awareness to an
issue and trying to do what you can to
support and so that's that's my goal
tonight I know a lot of people here are
doing the same all right who did you
come with tonight who's your date not
wrote the song home which is nominated
tonight about my family and my loved
ones and so it's a special thing to
share with him and I'll be crossing my
fingers and my arms and everything I can
promise where is Joe you go grab a drink
already Joe's like dude I'm not walking
the car have fun when you look back and
we've covered you guys for a long time
and you know you guys are these pop
sensations and now here you are at the
Golden Globes nominated as a songwriter
are you taking this in I'm trying to
this week's been crazy you know between
the Golden Globes and the beauty of
tonight celebrating film and television
and music as a part of that too Jumanji
number one of the box office it's a good
good day